Wem eine unberechtigte Abmahnung wegen angeblicher Urheberrechtsverstöße ins Haus flattert, kam bislang kaum um einen Anwalt herum. Insbesondere Freifunker, Betreiber von Flüchtlingsunterkünften und Freiwillige aus der Tor-Community, die sich häufig unberechtigten Abmahnungen gegenüber sehen, gehen mit ihrem Engagement oft Gefahr, Opfer solcher Abmahnungen zu werden. Da die Schreiben von Anschlägigen Kanzleien häufig vollautomatisch erstellt werden, werden Abmahnungen so zur Behinderung für freie Kommunikation. Daher stellen der Förderverein freie Netze und der Chaos Computer Club mit dem Abmahnbeantworter nun ein Werkzeug zur Verfügung, mit dem sich Betroffene wehren können. Nach dem Beantworten weniger Fragen erstellt das Tool ein versandfertiges Antwortschreiben. Das Tool und rechtliche Details findet ihr unter abmahnbeantworter.ccc.de Eine anonyme Gruppe namens Shadow Brokers stellt Angriffswerkzeuge ins Netz, die sie von der Equation Group erbeutet haben will. Diese wiederum steht in Zusammenhang mit der NSA. Die Unterlagen von Edward Snowden stützen die These, dass die Shadow Brokers tatsächlich Exploits und Root Kids der NSA besitzen. So taucht sowohl in der Software als auch in den Unterlagen ein identischer 16-stelliger Code auf. Unter den veröffentlichten Exploits befinden sich Angriffe gegen Router der Hersteller Cisco, Juniper, FortiGate und Topsec, die bereits mit Advisories reagiert, aber noch nicht alle Lücken gepatcht haben. Systemadministratoren sollten die Augen offen halten. Unterdessen vermutet Edward Snowden auf Twitter, dass sich hinter den Shadow Brokers der russische Geheimdienst verstecken könnte. Die öffentliche Bloßstellung sei dazu geeignet, die Außenpolitik der USA zu beeinflussen. Andere vermuten hinter der Tat einen Insider, der die Daten direkt aus der NSA gelegt hat. Auch eine Kombination beider Szenarien ist vorstellbar, falls es sich um einen Maulwurf handelt. Es bleibt jedenfalls spannend. Die Innenminister von Frankreich und Deutschland fordern nach ihrem Treffen, dass Anbieter von Kommunikationsdiensten im Internet wie etwa WhatsApp oder Signal bei der Entschlüsselung von Daten mithelfen sollen. Ein Papier fordert die EU-Kommission auf, entsprechende Gesetzesinitiativen zu ergreifen. Gleichzeitig solle die Verfügbarkeit starker Verschlüsselungssysteme gewahrt bleiben. Auch wenn das Papier keine konkreten Handlungsanweisungen zur Umsetzung enthält, deutet es den Einbau von Hintertüren an. Deutschland setzt mit CITES künftig vor allem auf den Aufkauf von Zero-Day-Exploits, um an Daten zu gelangen, die auf dem Transportweg verschlüsselt sind.
Und jetzt geht's los in die zweite Stunde des Chaosradios 226 mit Nitram.
Hallo.
Mit Varkar.
Hallöchen.
Mit Jasek.
Hallo.
Und mit Marco. Immer noch da? Immer noch da, sehr gut. Und wir hatten gerade so unglaublich abgefahrene Art und Weise, die auch immer komplizierter wurden, um ein Rechner oder ein Programm, denn darum geht es heute, Anwendungssicherheit, dazu zu verleiten, etwas zu tun, was es tun soll, indem man den Speicher manipuliert. Und wir sind da kompromittiert und sind dabei immer komplexer geworden. Und es wurde irgendwie immer unheimlicher. Wir hatten einen Non-Execution-Wild, wir hatten Speicherrandomisierung und wir haben festgestellt, so richtig hat es nicht was gebracht, aber einfach ist es jetzt auch nicht mehr so richtig. Da stelle ich mir die Fragen, ist das wirklich das tägliche Brot von Angreifern, so komplexe Dinge zu tun? Also Nitram hat ja schon gesagt, das ist gar nicht so komplex, es gibt da schon Tools. Aber muss man immer so weit gehen, um einem Programm dazu zu überreden, das zu tun, was man als Angreifer möchte? Gibt es da nicht auch noch einfachere Methoden?
Also es gibt natürlich immer die tiefhängenden Früchte, die ein Angreifer versucht zunächst zu ernten. Weil in der Regel genügt ein Sicherheitsproblem, um zum Ziel zu kommen. Und da nimmt man natürlich nicht die, die man am kompliziertesten ausnutzen kann, sondern die, die man am einfachsten ausnutzen und natürlich auch finden kann. Vor dem Ausnutzen steht immer noch das Finden. Es gab im April 2016 ein Business Report, Verizon Data Breach Investigation Report oder so ähnliches. Gesundheit. Und das Fazit...
Also es ging um den Telekommunikationsanbieter Verizon dabei.
Ja, die haben da natürlich auch eine Consulting-Klitsche da und haben eben diesen Report veröffentlicht und Fazit von diesem Report war, dass sie im Prinzip beobachten, seit 20 Jahren immer mit den gleichen Problemen zu tun zu haben und eben nicht so die esoterischen, schwer ausnutzenden Probleme, sondern irgendwie dieser ganze Standardgerümpel, den man im Prinzip auch schon vor 20 oder mehr Jahren hatte und ganz großer Klassiker ist natürlich der Umgang mit Passworten und da ist natürlich eine ganze Menge zu holen. Was auch immer wieder ein Problem sind, sind halt so Injection-Angriffe und das geht historisch gesehen ganz schön weit zurück, um das mal zu erläutern. Also es gab ja irgendwann mal ein Telefonsystem, wo Vermittlungsstellen existierten, bei denen Menschen Kabel in Buchsen steckten, um so eine Verbindung herzustellen.
Das vorneil vom Amt.
Genau und irgendwann wurde das mal automatisiert und dazu wurde ein System benutzt, wo innerhalb vom Datenkanal, also das Mikrofon, in das man hineinspricht, dieser Datenkanal, in diesem Datenkanal wurden auch Kommandos übertragen, um zum Beispiel eine Telefonnummer zu übertragen, damit irgendwelche Release gesteuert werden und da gab es diverse Signalisierungen und Leute, Hacker, sind auf die Idee gekommen, diese Signalisierungen einfach direkt in den Datenkanal zu injizieren. Beispielsweise gab es da Spezialkommandos, womit man dem Telefonsystem sagen konnte, hier Gegenstelle hängen mal bitte auf, aber die eigene Vermittlungsstelle, die war trotzdem noch verbunden und dann konnte man zum Beispiel Kosten anderer telefonieren, indem man erst mal eine kostenfreie Nummer anrief, aber dann eine halb getrennte Verbindung schuf durch das Senden bestimmter Kommandos und dann konnte man aber trotzdem noch mit dem Telefonsystem weiter kommunizieren und weitere Fehlbefehle sozusagen übersenden. Das gab es in 5000 Spielarten, es gab Systeme, wo man dem Telefonsystem sagen konnte, ich habe hier gerade eine Münze eingeworfen und das Guthaben reicht jetzt auch aus, um noch weiter telefonieren zu können. Und diese Vermischung von Daten und Steuerkanälen, das ist ein Sicherheitsproblem, das zieht sich im Prinzip schon durch die Dekaden, eben über diese Injectionangriffe. Da gibt es verschiedene Spielarten, zum Beispiel gibt es gerade bei Web-Anwendungen, das wollten wir jetzt hier allerdings ausklammern, diese SQL Injections, wenn da noch eine Datenbank dahinter hängt, gibt es aber auch Lokalen. Viele Telefon-Applikationen benutzen eine Datenbank, um Daten zwischenzuspeichern, Konfigurationen oder User-Daten. Und auch da kann man im Prinzip durch geeignete Konstruktionen von zu bearbeitenden Daten Kommandos einschleusen. In diesem Datenkanal kippt man dann zum Beispiel Datenbankbefehle ein und die werden dann verarbeitet. Oder ja, das gibt es halt an tausend Stellen.
Varkas, unser Profi für die Fachbegriffe.
SQL Injection wurde schon genannt, aber was so häufig da genommen wird, ist halt so gerade Delimiter, also irgendwie Hochkommentars, Minusminus, um Kommentare einzuleiten und solche Geschichten, um um den Code dahinter halt ja auszuklammern, sag ich mal.
Genau, was in Kreisen da gerne rumgeschickt wird, ist der XKCD Little Bobby Tables.
Richtig, das ist sehr zu empfehlen.
Genau, Entschuldigung, ich wollte dich nicht.
Ja, und das gibt es halt in 1000 Varianten. Es gibt LDAP Injections, wenn man ein System hat, was die Daten in so ein LDAP String reinhemmert und das Ding gegen so ein LDAP Server wirft, dann kann man da halt auch sozusagen die LDAP Query auch erweitern. Das Ganze gibt es dann irgendwie als XML Injection, wenn so ein XML Parse, so ein XML Dokument verwaltet, dann kann man in dem XML Dokument mit untersagen, ach hier, guck mal bitte in der Datei XY, da stehen noch irgendwelche XML Entitäten.
Warte, ich kann in XML verursachen, dass der Parse andere Dateien aufmacht?
Ja, das sind diese XML External Entities. Und dann kannst du sagen, hier, guck mal in etc.pass.vd, vielleicht findest du ja einen validen XML Code und wenn es ganz schlimm läuft, dann hast du das halt als Antwort ausgelesen.
Ja, bitte.
Locify Inclusion.
Ja oder bei OWASP heißt das XML External Entity, la la la.
Das grundsätzliche Problem ist halt hier, dass wie häufig, dass man ein sehr komplexes System hat, zum Beispiel ein XML-Parser und dass man als Programmierer nur einen Bruchteil davon benutzt und sich in dem Moment nicht bewusst ist, dass dieses System in Wirklichkeit viel, viel, viel größer ist und dass da dann teilweise in Ecken des Systems unerwartete Features schlummern.
Es überrascht mich halt auch, weil ich so denke, XML, das ist die Sprache für das Internet und dann irgendwie da nicht nachgedacht. Das schockiert mich jetzt gerade so.
Flash ist auch das. Genau, Flash ist ja auch die Grafik des, wissen Sie schon.
Ich möchte da nicht drüber reden, aber du hast natürlich vollkommen recht.
Also komplexe Systeme haben interessante Fehler.
Komplexe Probleme oder triviale Fehler.
Ja, gut, dieses Injection-Themen-Gebiet kann man natürlich irgendwie beliebig vertiefen, weil wenn irgendwie verschiedene Systeme miteinander verheiratet werden, dann gibt es halt immer irgendwie Brüche. Also ich will jetzt hier nicht zu kriminellen Handlungen aufrufen, aber es gibt da draußen im Internet ganz viele, ich kann hier online LaTeX schreiben und da gibt es natürlich auch irgendwie diverse Problematiken, dass man zum Beispiel in LaTeX auch Kommandos einschleusen kann, wie inkludiere mal diese Datei. Und schwuppdiwupp hat man bei diesen 5000 online, wir rendern hier mal LaTeX zusammen zu einem PDF, dann hat man ganz fix die Passwort-Dateien ausgelesen.
Best Practice ist glaube ich da, das dann wieder einfach in irgendeine Art von Virtualisierung oder Container zuzupacken.
Genau, ich hab mal irgendwie so einen Online-Service, ich hab da mal ein bisschen rumgeforscht und hab dann irgendwann mal so einen Online-Service angeschrieben und die meinten, ja alles halb so wild, sie benutzen jetzt hier Docker.
Ja, zur Information, Docker ist sowas wie eine Sandbox. Genau.
Genau, das eigentliche Problem ist nicht gefixt, aber das Problem ist so weit abgeschwächt, dass es nicht sofort alles auseinanderfällt.
Genau. Also statt es richtig zu machen, nimmt man sich ein Brett und zwei Nägel und hofft, dass es hält. Beziehungsweise die bessere Analogie ist eigentlich, man stellt einen Eimer unter und leert ihn für jede Benutzung wieder aus. Das heißt, es ist völlig egal, was in diesem Eimer landet.
Man braucht halt eine zweite Sicherheitslücke.
Das Loch im Eimer, genau. Okay, also letztendlich, man schaut sich an, was man so mit XML machen kann. Das ist ja schon ziemlich scary. Aber ich befürchte, das ist noch nicht alles, oder?
Naja, wenn wir beim Thema XML und Beispiele sind, dann gibt es da ein sehr schönes Beispiel, was auch mehrere Sachen vereint, nämlich hauptsächlich unerwartete Komplexität. Und wir mischen auch mal hier irgendwie Code und Daten zusammen. Es gibt ja dieses Scalable Vector Graphics Format SVG, was modern ist, und da steht in der Spezifikation, dass man bei SVG auch Code einschleusen kann, also den kann man sozusagen mit der SVG Datei transportieren, und dieser Code kommt zur Ausführung, um Sachen zu rendern. Und da gibt es in der Lautspezifikation zwei Möglichkeiten, entweder JavaScript oder man kann auch eine URL mit Java Code angeben. Und je nachdem, wie das Framework damit umgeht, kann einem das auf die Füße fallen oder nicht. Da gab es dieses Open Source Framework Bartek, und da gab es auch so Tools, die das dann einfach dann ausgeführt haben. Und das ist natürlich dann nicht so, wie man das will, aber das stand halt immer in der Spezifikation. Hat halt niemand wirklich realisiert, dass das auch mal daneben gehen kann.
Das heißt im schlimmsten Fall, ich lade mir so eine SVG Datei runter, lebe mir die Lokale angucken und fange mir da unter Umständen.
Was da gegebenenfalls ein bisschen geläufiger ist, ist PDF. PDF ist so ein ganz böses Format, wo dann halt auch Action-Script und sowas wird ausgewählt.
Na ja, du sagst geläufiger. Also, ich meine, man lädt sich ja nicht häufig SVG-Dateien runter, aber ein Punkt, wo auf ganz, ganz vielen Computern heutzutage SVG eingesetzt wird, ist Emoji. Diese kleinen Smiley-Gesichter, die ich in meinem, zum Beispiel Android, in der Text-Anwendung, also in der Nachrichten-Anwendung habe. Und zwar werden die in vielen heutigen Fonts so gebaut, also so eine Schriftart, die ist ja dafür verantwortlich, wie ein gewisses Zeichen auf meinem Bild schon dargestellt wird. Und das ist ja auch nur eine Datei. Und jetzt hat man, als man sich überlegt hat, wie man diese bunten Bilder in dieser Datei kodieren möchte, sich natürlich gedacht, müssen wir vielleicht nicht alle selber bauen, können wir ja was Existierendes nehmen. Das heißt, was sie gemacht haben, ist, sie haben im OpenType Format, also einem der meisten verwendeten Standardformate für Schriftarten, spezifiziert. Okay. Und wenn das nicht reicht, was OpenType eingebaut hat, dann kannst du hier SVG reintun. Und auf die Art und Weise führt im Endeffekt mein Browser oder andere Programme, bei denen ich dafür sorgen kann, dass eine Schriftart von mir geladen wird als Angreifer, führt dieses Programm meinen SVG-Code aus.
Also auch meine ganzen total vertrauenswürdigen Messenger.
Na gut, bei Messenger kann ich die Schriftart im Allgemeinen nicht kontrollieren. Aber zum Beispiel beim Browser kann ich das.
Okay, das stimmt natürlich. Aber ich könnte mir, es gibt ja genügend Apps heutzutage, wo man sich eigene Emojis, die noch mal fancierer sind, runterlädt. Und das heißt, wenn die App selber noch nicht shady ist, die Emojis sind es möglicherweise.
Ja, und technisch gibt es sogar, es gibt sogar ein Apple-Standard, wie man dann gleich die komplette Schriftart mit dem Emoji und dem SVG drin in die Datei selber reinpackt, wenn es eine PDF oder so ist.
Aber dazu muss man sagen, dass du dann eine App installieren musst, wo die Emojis installiert sind.
Und in dem Moment ist... Das kann ich dir sagen, das passiert durchaus häufiger.
Ja, aber dann brauchst du theoretisch auch die Emojis nicht mehr, wenn du eine App installierst.
Nein, nein, nein, eine andere App, die eine andere App dann kompromittieren soll. Ja, aber ja, ich sehe was. Oh man, also SVG auch ganz furchtbar.
Das setzt natürlich voraus, dass das Framework dann auch tatsächlich da diesen Code anfasst. Ich glaube, bei den meisten Frameworks ist das wahrscheinlich ausgeschaltet. Aber gut, das gibt wahrscheinlich dann noch 5000 andere low-hanging fruits, die tiefhängenden Früchte, deren man sich bedienen kann.
Ganz wichtig, das würde ich noch gerne mit aufnehmen, ist auf jeden Fall, einer der häufigsten Fehler sind Standardinstallationen. Die Konfigurationen sind unter Umständen nicht immer die sichersten, sondern sie sollen halt meistens laufen. Dazu gehört natürlich auch das, was schon Nitram angesprochen hatte, Standardpasswörter. Aber gerade die Konfigurationen sind normalerweise so, dass sie immer laufen sollen.
Baga an die Zuhörer, wer hat das Passwort auf seinem Router geändert? Bitte jetzt aufzeigen. Ich sehe keine Hände. Drei, okay, drei.
Du musst doch auch die Augen aufmachen.
Also, das Router ist ja mittlerweile auch wenigstens so, dass sie irgendeine Art von zufälligem Passwort haben. Ich mach hier Gänsefüßchen in die Hände, weil wir auch wissen, dass das natürlich auch leider teilweise zurückberechenbar ist. Aber es ist immerhin nicht mehr das Passwort. Das ist sicherlich auch eine Sache, die die Leute gelernt haben.
Also, ja, dazu gehören natürlich auch Probleme, die in der Logik an sich drin sind.
Ja, also in Logikprogrammen.
Also in der Logik von Programmen.
In der Logik von Programmen, verzeihung. Und welche wären das? Marco ist da, glaube ich, der prädestinierte Mensch, dafür, den wir uns dazu genommen haben. Naja, also im Endeffekt eigentlich ist, wo man am besten anfängt, ist eigentlich, dass alles, was Computer kennen, nur Zahlen sind. Das heißt, alles, auch Buchstaben, Bilder, was auch immer, sind halt als Zahlen repräsentiert. Und wenn man jetzt, oder wenn man halt Text hat, zum Beispiel, dann hat man halt zum Beispiel eine 97 als kleines A, eine 98 als kleines B, und so weiter und so weiter. Wenn man jetzt aber stattdessen halt irgendwie, wenn das Programm jetzt denkt, dass stattdessen an der Stelle eine Zahl steht, dann wird halt, was weiß ich, vier Buchstaben zusammen als Zahl interpretiert und dann passiert halt irgendwas anderes. Und ein Problem, was dann halt auch ist, dass halt absolut alles in diesen Zahlen dargestellt werden muss. Das heißt, teilweise hat man halt Sachen, wo man halt irgendwie spezielle Werte hat, die man halt eigentlich aus einem Wertbereich ausschließen will. Das heißt, man hat halt entweder eins von diesen paar tausend Möglichkeiten oder halt irgendwie, dass es keins von all diesen ist. Und da gab es zum Beispiel vor einer Weile in Sudo ein Programm, was man benutzt, um seine Rechte auf dem Rechner zu erweitern. Einen lustigen Bug. Den hast du sogar gefunden, ne? Oh, cool. Im Endeffekt, das hat so ein Bequemlichkeits-Feel drinne. Du musst halt immer dein Passwort eingeben, damit du halt einen Programm mit erweiterten Rechten ausführen darfst. Und damit du das halt nicht ständig machen musst, wenn du das innerhalb der letzten fünf Minuten eingegeben hast, dann brauchst du das Passwort nicht eingeben und das wird halt einfach so gemacht. Und wenn du jetzt halt irgendwie deinen Rechner irgendwie länger stehen lässt oder so und da auf Nummer sicher gehen willst, dass das nicht jemand verwenden kann, kannst neben dem den Rechner zu locken halt auch einfach sagen sudo-k, das setzt das Datum, was es sich dafür gemerkt hat, dann auf den 1.1.1970 0 Uhr.
Und das ist so lange zurück. Das heißt, die fünf Minuten sind rum.
Das heißt beim nächsten Mal musst du den Passwort eingeben, außer du darfst als User die Uhr ändern. Dann drehst du die Uhr auf den 1.1.1970 0 Uhr und so du prüfst 1.1.1970 0 Uhr und ein bisschen bis innerhalb der letzten fünf Minuten. Du darfst ohne Passwort. Und dürfen Benutzer das in der Regel?
Na ja, kommt auf das System an.
Unter macOS kann man das im Terminal nicht machen, aber in der GUI, wenn man nicht das explizit lockt.
Unter Ubuntu darf man das glaube ich auch.
Unter anderen Linuxen in der Regel nicht.
Also alles, was auf Benutzerbequemlichkeit ausgelegt ist, ist das dann halt leicht, dass das auch irgendwie funktioniert. Puh, aber das ist glaube ich was, was man gar nicht so schnell übersieht, weil ich wäre jetzt auch nicht davon ausgegangen, dass Benutzer das einfach so ändern dürfen, ohne sich eben durch so einen Mechanismus wie eben Sudo noch mal zu legitimieren. Na ja, unter Windows darf das glaube ich auch so ziemlich jeder User. Also außer auf Mehrbenutzersystemen, wo das dann halt explizit weg konfiguriert wird oder? Genau, das stimmt, aber da habe ich auch kein Sudo.
Aber daran sieht man mal wieder, dass Convenience halt genau die Gegenstelle zu Security ist. Also Convenience und Security ist halt so gut wie unmöglich.
Ja, ich bin mir da nicht ganz sicher. Da gibt es ja irgendwie verschiedene Schulen, die einen sagen doch irgendwie, das schließt sich aus, und anderen sagen, na ja, wenn man es denn halt nur gescheit designen würde, sodass ich dann so quasi direkt mit Security im Kopf dann ginge da schon einiges, würde dir da nicht zustimmen?
Also ich nicht.
Naja, also ein grundsätzlicher Trend, den man schon beobachten kann, ist, dass modernere Systeme, in die viel Geld gesteckt wurde, tendenziell sicherer sind als weniger moderne Systeme, in die viel Geld gesteckt wurde. Also wenn man sich zum Beispiel die modernen Mobilbetriebssysteme anschaut, irgendwie das iOS, was auf iPhones ausgeliefert wird, und Android, die sind gegenüber ihren Desktop-Vorgängern, nenne ich das mal, durchaus aus theoretischer Sicht eleganter geworden auf eine gewisse Art und Weise. Zum Beispiel hat Android ein sehr feines Berechtigungsmodell, was auch für alle Anwendungen durchgesetzt wird. Alle Anwendungen haben gegeneinander eine sehr gute Isolation, deutlich besser, als das auf einem Desktop-Linux der Fall wäre. Obwohl ein Android auch nur ein Linux ist. Das konnte in dem Fall gemacht werden, weil dieses System mehr oder weniger von Null auf, from scratch, designt wurde. Und man nicht die Verpflichtung hatte, dass bestehende Programme darauf laufen müssen.
Gut, aber da macht man sich natürlich auch ein bisschen leicht, weil man viele Dinge, die auf dem Desktop laufen, um dort Dateien im Dateisystem zu speichern. Also so Dateisysteme per se, die viele Probleme verursachen, die gibt es ja nicht, weil die ganzen Sachen werden in der Cloud gespeichert. Und die Cloud macht ja nochmal ganz andere Probleme, über die wir aber heute Abend nicht reden wollen.
Was ich noch als Logikfehler mit aufnehmen würde, wären, glaube ich, die interessanten Implikationen, die gerade durch Encoding entstehen.
Encoding erzähl doch erstmal. Was meinst du mit Encoding?
Encoding ist quasi die Repräsentation. Wie Marco schon gesagt hat, alles ist ja eine Zahl für den Computer. Und dies Encoding sagt halt, welche Zahl, welchen Buchstaben für den Benutzer darstellen sollte.
Also bei Zeichenketten.
Ja, gutes Beispiel ist ja immer Umlaute. Da kennt man ja diverse Arten, wie die plötzlich aussehen können. Und wenn jetzt bestimmte Programme mit interessanten Encodings ausgeführt werden, dann verstehen sie plötzlich bei irgendeiner Stringrepräsentation irgendwas anders, als wenn sie auf einem anderen Computer laufen. Und das kann halt unter Umständen zu Problemen führen. So die einfachste Variante ist dann halt, dass sie den Benutzernamen falsch interpretieren. Oder das Passwort oder wie auch immer. Das sind die einfachsten Varianten.
Hilf mir mal, ob das ungefähr das Problem ist, was ich hier sehe auf unserem Aufnahmeprogramm. Da hab ich ein Hauptgerät. Warum hab ich ein Hauptgerät und kein Hauptgerät? Und meine Vermutung ist, dass bei der Längenberechnung... Genau, bei der Längenberechnung. Kannst du das besser erklären als nur Multibytes?
Ja, jetzt wird's übel. UTF-8.
Ich glaube, ich kann das versuchen. Im Endeffekt ist man halt hingegangen und hat entschieden, dass man mehr als nur die im Englischen verwendeten Zeichen durch Zahlen darstellen möchte. Nun braucht man natürlich für alle Schriftzeichen dieser Erde ganz schön viele Zahlen. Der am weitesten verbreitete Standard, der Unicode-Standard, listet aktuell über 100.000 verschiedene Schriftzeichen. Nun ist die Standardgröße für eine Zahl auf einem Computer ein Byte. Ein Byte kann nur Werte bis 256 fassen. Erst hat man sich natürlich die Frage gestellt, okay, wie kriege ich nun mit Bytes all diese Zahlen dargestellt? Und anstatt für jedes Zeichen einfach mehrere Bytes zu verwenden, hat man sich nun überlegt, okay, der meiste Text, den ich auf meinem Computer benutze, ist ja sowieso irgendwie mehr oder weniger Englisch. Und was man jetzt gemacht hat, ist, dass man sich ein System ausgedacht hat, wie für zum Beispiel englische Zeichen Zahlen des Wertebereichs bis 256 verwendet werden, allerdings für Zeichen, die nicht mehr in diesen Wertebereich hineinpassen, dann bestimmte magische Folgen von Zahlen verwendet werden, die der Computer eindeutig erkennen kann, die dann für eine einzige größere Zahl wiederum stehen. Und im Endeffekt, was in deinem Fall halt geschehen ist, ist, du hast eine Zeichenkette, die aus ganz, ganz vielen englischen Zeichen besteht, auf Name G, das sind ja alles Buchstaben, die gibt es in der englischen Sprache, und dem Ä, das gibt es da nicht. Das heißt, das Ä muss nun durch eine Zahl, oder wird in diesem Fall durch eine Zahl dargestellt, die größer als, oder die in dem Fall größer als etwas unter 256 ist. Und diese Zahl muss nun vom Computer durch zwei Bytes dargestellt werden.
Weil das Ä quasi nichts ist, was die englische Sprache kennt.
Ja, das ist nicht an Englisch gekoppelt, das hat sie sehr historische Gründe, warum das so aussieht, wie es aussieht. Im Endeffekt ist dieses Ä in diesem erweiterten Wertebereich. Deswegen werden zwei Bytes zur Kodierung verwendet, statt für andere Buchstaben ein Byte. Mit dem Ergebnis, dass diese Zeichenkette aus einem Byte mehr besteht, als sie aus Zeichen besteht. Ich zähle jetzt nicht ihr Buchstabenaufnahmegerät im Kopf, aber wenn ich mir das zum Beispiel an ein Gerät anschaue, dann habe ich G-E-R-Ä-T als Buchstaben, aber der Computer sieht da ein Byte mehr, weil das Ä in zwei Byte kodiert ist. Ein häufiger Programmierfehler ist, dass ich bei einer Zeichenkette aus Versehen die Bytelänge als Länge der Zeichenkette im Buchstaben nehme, oder umgekehrt die Länge der Zeichenkette im Buchstaben als Länge des Puffers in Byte, aber dann kopiere ich da was rein und dann ist ein Zeichen auf einmal breiter und dann kriege ich halt Fehler in verschiedene Richtungen. Also entweder, dass ich einen Puffer habe, der zu schmal ist, oder dass ich in deinem Fall halt, dass ich zu wenig Zeichen aus diesem Puffer wiederum ausgebe.
Und wenn ich jetzt in der Lage bin, als Angreifer diese Zeichenkette zu manipulieren oder zu beeinflussen, dann kann das unter Umständen zu Problemen führen?
Ja, die kann plötzlich doppelt so lang werden. Und dann hätte man wieder einen Pufferüberlauf oder einen Pufferaufschub zum Beispiel. Oder man kann Fehler umgehen.
Das heißt, wer da nochmal darauf zurück will, der spult nochmal kurz zurück in die erste Stunde, wo wir das kurz angesprochen haben. Aber ich glaube, das ist eine tatsächlich sehr, sehr schöne Erklärung. So, und damit haben wir wieder eine halbe Stunde abgeschlossen. Und dann spielen wir jetzt noch eine kleine Musik. Und dann müssen die Herren nochmal ran und mir erklären, wie das jetzt eigentlich alles anders sein müsste. Und wir hören uns jetzt von Infinite Freefall gutted. So, das ist die letzte halbe Stunde hier im Chaosradio 226, wo wir uns ein wenig unterhalten haben über Anwendungssicherheit. Und was mich jetzt eigentlich noch so ein bisschen umtreibt, ist, wir haben jetzt so viel gehört an Low Hanging Fruit, an Sachen, wo man wirklich tief einsteigen muss. Aber wird es jemals besser werden? Was kann man überhaupt tun, um sich da so ein bisschen gegen zu wehren?
Es wird nie besser werden. Wir können im Grunde heute damit aufhören, alle Computer verbrennen und...
Ich glaube, es wird schon besser. Man sieht ja auch, dass es besser wird. Allein anhand der Fehlerklassen, die so im Laufe der Zeit aufpoppen, und das wird halt auch auf einer Weise immer spezieller, den Fehlerklassen und immer komplizierter die auszunutzen. Auf der anderen Seite, mal abgesehen von den Low Hanging Fruits, sieht man auch, dass sich der Aufwand fürs Angreifen immer weiter erhöht.
Aber meine These ist eigentlich eine andere. Ich stelle jetzt mal die These auf, man wird nicht hinterherkommen, weil Hersteller immer mit neuer Technologie herkommen, weil sie immer unter dem Druck stehen, neue Sachen zu liefern. Und weil der Druck, neue Sachen zu liefern, höher ist, als der Druck, die Sachen ordentlich zu machen. Oder manchmal bedenkt man auch nicht alles, selbst bei bester Absicht.
Gut, ich glaube, das schließt sich alles nicht aus. Es gibt ja auch den Trend, dass immer mehr Komplexität auf die Rechner kommt. Und auf der anderen Seite natürlich immer nur ein Fehler genügt, um ein System zu Fall zu bringen. Mehr Komplexität, sowieso mehr von allem. Wenn man sich das so als Grafen vorstellt, dann wächst das immer wilder. Und irgendwas ist für den Angreifer immer dabei.
Und eine andere Sache, die ich auch mal aufstellen würde, ist alte Sachen kommen immer wieder. Alte Probleme kommen immer wieder entweder in neuen Kombinationen.
Google-Suchbegriff Internet of Shit.
IoT, yeah.
Also ihr meint einfach das Internet of Things. Das wäre eigentlich ausklammern wollen, wenn wir nicht über das Internet reden.
Aber da läuft auch Softwarelokal drauf. Da laufen auch Anwendungen drauf.
Im Grunde ist das Problem halt, dass ständig Software geschrieben wird und produziert wird und deutlich mehr Software in jeder Sekunde geschrieben wird, als von Leuten nach Sicherheitslücken durchsucht wird. Das heißt, wir haben einen ständig anwachsenden Haufen an potentiell unsicherer Software und wir kommen einfach nicht hinterher, das alles zu überprüfen. Das ist uns jetzt im letzten paar Jahren ein paar Mal auf die Füße gefallen. Stichwort OpenSSL, aber auch einer der Jeep Hacks, wo sie ein Auto gehackt haben, im Endeffekt über eine Lücke in einem der Decoder für den Radiodatenstrom, den dieses Auto empfangen hat. Also Musik, da war eine Lücke in dem Decoder und darüber haben sie dann die Kontrolle über das Auto übernommen. Und diese Lücke, das war jetzt auch nichts Besonderes in der Hinsicht. Aber dadurch, dass wir so eine, dass in jedem System, jedem computerbasierten System, was man heute in der Hand hält, so unglaublich unvorstellbar viel Komplexität und viel Software drinsteckt, gibt es schlicht nicht, kann man schlicht als Entwickler und auch als Sicherheitsforscher nicht mehr den Überblick über das gesamte System haben.
Aber das ist sozusagen eines dieser Punkte, die ich in meiner These drin hatte. Das ist halt gerade jetzt im Autobereich mit all den Innovationen und DASMUS noch und dieser Sensor noch und dieses Komfortmerkmal noch. Das ist ja im Prinzip genau das, was ich beschrieben habe, jetzt auf das konkrete Beispiel Auto runtergebrochen.
Ja, dazu muss man sagen, dass der Weg, den der Desktop, sag ich mal, oder die Consumer Electronics vielleicht ein bisschen zu weit gefasst, ist quasi so, dass der Desktop heutzutage als relativ gut abgesichert im Allgemeinen geht. Also man kann sich halt nicht mehr, indem man halt einen Desktop einfach so ins Internet anschließt, es sei denn, er ist wirklich zehn Jahre nicht gepatcht worden oder was weiß ich. Wenn man jetzt einen heutzutage einen Windows XP anschließt, okay. Aber ich sag mal, wenn man jetzt ein frische installiertes Windows 10 oder was weiß ich ins Netz hängt, dann ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit relativ gering, dass man innerhalb der ersten fünf Minuten geohnt wird.
Es sei denn, man lädt sich irgendwelche lustigen Dinge runter oder klickt auf irgendwelche...
Ich rede nur vom Betrieb. Ich rede nur vom direkten Reinhängen. Also ich rede jetzt nicht davon, dass jetzt irgendwie der die Nutzerin auf komischen Seiten sich rumtreibt. Aber diesen Weg hat sogenannte Embedded Software noch vor sich. Also in den ganzen Routern, Internet of Things Geräten, da findet man das Ganze, was wir heute eigentlich größtenteils als Abwehrmaßnahmen besprochen haben, noch gar nicht.
Und Marco hatte glaube ich auch, wie siehst du das? Also wird das irgendwann besser? Naja, also auf der einen Seite werden die Abwehrmechanismen halt immer besser und das Problem wird sich LON irgendwo so ein bisschen reduzieren. Auf der anderen Seite ist halt allein dadurch, dass Computer halt mehr oder weniger logikbasiert sind, ist halt von vornherein klar, dass es nie sicher sein kann, weil man halt einfach so komische Sätze bilden kann, wie dieser Satz ist falsch oder einen kleinen Tick komplexer, wenn du das erste versuchst, rauszufiltern. Der nächste Satz ist falsch, der vorhergehende Satz ist wahr. Und so immer weiter. Also das macht keinen Sinn, die Aussage?
Wir Menschen haben mit solchen selbstreferenziellen Sachen kein Problem für Computer.
Also wir sagen, was soll das? Aber der Computer würde das einfach hinnehmen. Genau. Und Güdel's Unvollständigkeitssatz zum Beispiel und noch viele andere solche theoretischen Ergebnisse. Bitte wer? Güdel hat im Endeffekt das mit der Mathematik halt mal gemacht. So genau so einen Satz quasi einfach als mathematische Formel mehr oder weniger konstruiert und damit gezeigt, dass was auch immer wir benutzen, um Mathematik zu formalisieren, nie sich selbst als korrekt beweisen kann, sondern wir halt immer so das Inner Schwebe haben. Das könnte unsicher sein. Also es könnten halt Fehler drin sein. Wir könnten halt irgendwie Schluss beweisen. Das heißt, die Wissenschaft sagt, es wird nie sicher.
Sicherheit ist ein Prozess, kein Zustand.
Und das deprimiert mich heute ganz schön.
Ja, also es gibt die üblichen Dinge, die halt ein Benutzer tun kann. Das ist halt irgendwie Firewall, Anti-Viren-Software installieren. Aber darüber hinaus.
Ja, macht das das wirklich sicherer?
Das ist ein Wunderpunkt, weil wir uns gerne gerade in den letzten Monaten...
Ich wollte gerade sagen, das Wichtigste daran ist eigentlich zu gucken, ist das, was ich hier abberufe überhaupt sinnvoll. Beziehungsweise man sollte nicht auf jede E-Mail gucken. Also gerade so, was in letzter Zeit die üblichen Angriffe sind, sind auch gerade auf den Menschen, sogenanntes Social Engineering. Und da sollte man vielleicht halt mal gucken, ob der Mensch nicht in den Vordergrund tritt und nicht gerade die Anwendung. Ganz einfache Sachen. Ich bekomme eine E-Mail. Dort drin steht, hier, Paypal, bitte die Kreditkarten überprüfen. Und da ist ein Link drin. Und wenn man allein schon mit der Maus über diesen Button hovert, dann sieht man unten meistens schon, wo es hingeht. Und wenn da jetzt irgendwie sento.to x, y, z drinsteht und nicht paypal.com, dann ist irgendwas schon mal komisch. Und da sollte man vielleicht nicht drauf drücken. Da gibt es einen Rechtsklick und dann kann man auch drücken, Betrugsversuch melden.
Okay, also du redest jetzt von ganz klassischem Social Engineering.
Funktioniert häufig, teilweise besser als irgendwelche Anwendungssicherheitslücken zu finden. Weil stellt man sich vor, man schickt 50 Millionen E-Mails, also Spam oder Phishing-E-Mails, es gibt mindestens ein Prozent, würde ich behaupten, die darauf reinfallen. Also Anwendung ist das eine.
Also immer Augen offen halten, immer zusehen, dass man seine...
Also direkte Angriffe, dass die dich jetzt direkt angreifen, ist eher selten. Sie nutzen heutzutage den Menschen als Sicherheitslücke.
Das ist ein interessanter Aspekt, wann würde man denn wirklich zu den härteren Waffen greifen? Also wann ist Spam quasi nicht mehr das Mittel der Wahl? Muss ich da wirklich schon irgendwie die NSA sein? Oder gibt es da auch noch andere Leute, die vielleicht interessiert sind? Also lohnt sich das unterhalb eines Staates, solche Sachen zu machen? Wenn du jetzt sagst, das ist viel einfacher, dann schicke ich die Leute natürlich auf meine Adresse.
Ich glaube, da gibt es tausend Kombinationen, wo Angriffe Sinn machen. Allein diese Verschlüsselungstrojaner, die einen Rechner befallen, die Daten verschlüsseln und dann Geld fordern für die Herausgabe von der Originaldaten zeigen, dass im Prinzip jeder da Daten speichert und verarbeitet, die er gerne auch behalten möchte. Und zeigt auch, dass das Angriffe sind, womit man viel Geld verdienen kann. Und ich glaube, bei den meisten börsennotierten Unternehmen, wenn man da einen Fuß in der Tür hat und irgendwie interne Informationen herauszieht, sind die sofort Geld wert, weil man die entweder selbst einsetzen kann oder verkaufen kann. Okay, also man muss kein Staat sein, um Angriffsziele zu machen.
Das sind sozusagen einfach, je nachdem, welches Ziel man verfolgt.
In der Regel will ein Angreifer irgendwie Geld haben. Also die meisten Angreifer. Oder Kontrolle über...
Oder Informationen, die er hinterher zu Geld machen kann.
Wenn man ein Dispote ist und Leute unterdrücken möchte, wäre das zum Beispiel auch eine Möglichkeit, um, wie jetzt mit bestimmten Journalisten passiert ist, dass sie denen irgendwelche Beweise für kriminelle Taten untergeschoben haben, in denen sie versucht haben, Malware zu installieren oder sämtliche anderen Sachen. Also wenn ich jetzt versuchen würde, meine Opposition zu unterdrücken, in irgendeiner Art und Weise wäre das zum Beispiel auch eine Möglichkeit.
Okay, also wir sehen schon, es wird irgendwie keine perfekte Sicherheit geben. Es gibt tausend Angriffsmöglichkeiten. Also was tun wir letztendlich? Was tun wir als Anwender oder was ratet ihr Anwendern, was sie tun sollen? Sie können sich ja offensichtlich nicht wehren. Das heißt, man kann nur präventiv tätig werden letztendlich.
Updates installieren.
Standard.
Okay, also Updates installieren, Backups machen, etc. Das ist ja irgendwie...
Mau.
Das ist sehr, sehr mau. Also ich hätte jetzt auch irgendwie erwartet, dass das hier ein bisschen mehr bei rumkommt, aber offensichtlich...
Es gibt halt kein Silver Bullet in dem Sinne oder ein Allheilmittel. Im Endeffekt braucht das eine gewisse Bemühung von allen Seiten, sowohl von den Leuten, die Software schreiben, als auch von den Leuten, die das Thema administrieren, als auch von dem Endanwender. Auf allen Seiten, aber besonders auf Seiten der Endanwender, eine Sache, die schon sehr, sehr viel hilft, ist, wenn ich versuche, wenigstens einigermaßen zu verstehen, womit ich es zu tun habe und wie das funktioniert, weil ich dadurch schon relativ häufig Angriffsversuche anhand von unnormalem Verhalten erkennen kann. Zum Beispiel sehe ich in einer Spam oder in einer Phishing-E-Mail, kann ich dann anhand der URL erkennen, dass das nicht paypal.com ist und dass ich in diese Login-Seite nicht meine Paypal-Daten eingeben sollte.
Mit anderen Worten, Awareness schaffen, Aufmerksamkeit schaffen, Leute schulen.
Beste Variante.
Okay, das heißt, das ist mindestens so wertvoll und wichtig, wie Backups machen.
Weil die meisten Angriffe wie gesagt nicht direkt passieren, sondern eher jetzt heutzutage durch die ganzen Sicherheitsmaßnahmen eher auf den Menschen ziehen.
Okay, gut, dann würde ich sagen, machen wir an der Stelle, haben wir noch was vergessen? Das ist ja immer die wichtigste Frage. Legt euch noch irgendwas auf dem Herzen.
Also vergessen haben wir bestimmt ganz, ganz, ganz viel. Das Thema würde ja Bücher füllen oder diverse Podcasts. Insofern haben wir sicherlich ganz viele Themen hier einfach auslassen müssen.
Das ist aber denke ich vollkommen okay. Es gibt ja noch die Show Notes, die hier fleißig mit tippen und auf die möchte ich dann auch verweisen für weitere Informationen. Ansonsten könnt ihr es gerne auf dem Blog Kommentare hinterlassen.
Mich würde persönlich auch mal interessieren, ob die Zubehörer daran interessiert sind, die Schauer gegebenenfalls das Thema ein bisschen zu intensivieren.
Also mehr Übersicherheit in diversen Aspekten. Da wird schon geklatscht. Also auch da könnt ihr uns gerne Feedback zu geben, ob und in welcher Form ihr das gerne hättet. Ansonsten mache ich das Thema jetzt hier zu. Das war Chaosradio 226 und ich verabschiede mich von Nitram.
Ja, bis zum nächsten Mal.
Von Vakar. Und von Jasek.
Gute Nacht.
Und ich wünsche euch alles Gute. Das nächste Mal gibt es dann Chaosradio 227, wieder von Fritz, wieder mit Markus Richter. Und ich bin Danimo und wünsche euch noch einen schönen Tag oder eine schöne Nacht, wo immer ihr auch seid. Macht's gut, tschüss.